hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play hide with a
why not to be confused with hide with an
i which was a very pixelated but very
good game that I played recently or a
while back on my channel this is a newly
released game made on the Unity engine
like a lot of new games are because it's
a very good engine for any developers
but it's supposedly really good and
exceptionally scary so far so not that
you seem pretty simple but I mean it's a
game developer just trying to get by so
you know yes huh the plebs can't believe
I have to do this yeah so paint lemma
some corporate jockey trying to make do
in his sad life go out the fire exit
nope ok so I don't even know how to open
a door oh wait those the doors already
open why is this one written in red oh
oh I'm done with work okay
nice place hmm
just because you run a company doesn't
oh so you're running the country I was
ecstatic huh interesting nice computer
I'm jelly breath whoa wait what I wasn't
done exploring
something's happened something has
changed I'm pretty sure it's on the tip
of my nose as to what it is oh yeah
things have gone pastel and all film
grain Ian there's hairs in my eyeballs
apparently what's that oh this is your
contentious school uh-huh
yeah yeah this has douchebag written all
over it I think you deserve exactly what
happened to you
Northwood hmm indeed yes I'll start
talking like this guy now run forgot
this even this place wasn't worthy of my
knowledge and skill my level of academia
was much higher in this place deserved
before I am the son of henrik von
Slayton boom Emperor or leader heir to
the Sladen boom throne air company of
course yeah hello that looks good
ooh quite pretty I like this Sun shafts
this seems almost nice I'm wondering
when things are gonna turn diabolical
and I still think that this guy deserves
everything that's gonna happen to him I
already do not like him
something about pretentiousness people
don't like their head shoved so far up
their ass can't even hear them speak can
i sprint this is getting kind of tedious
I wonder how long this game is because
if this intra has anything to do with it
I mean it's my I might be in for a quite
a long game the download is very large
hello yeah I never remembered huh anyway
what I was supposed to go to the right
wall art I dick Gabba and bring on this
scares no I'm actually just kidding I
actually like I like the intro sequence
that they're doing it's just a bit slow
and seems like there could be a bit more
focus here but I mean other than that
it's actually pretty cool I felt
different mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah
alternate you where am I going am I even
going the right way I'm not sure it
seems like there could have been other
ways yeah mm-hmm I hear something
terrible from you
you're foggy eyeballs what's in here
hello
looks like standard classroom affair ah
the door closed on me ah okay alright
I'll go to the front of the class fine
screw you
what's that chalkboard chalk huh yeah
exactly
oh all right I think things are about to
begin
I'm back in my house now some flashback
Oh time to get ready for the morning get
my coffee my standard douche bag pills
yeah
op operating another flashback
what uh-oh this is a hospital of some
sort this place was one of healing yeah
oh okay defective elevators gurney
conveniently blocking the way shadow all
right
things have started to take a creepier
turn mmm was arguing with the
receptionist about mother's treatment
yeah at that moment I felt the haps the
closest thing to a fiction I could hmm
surprising
I might be I hope you guys don't think
I'm being overly critical I actually do
like the setup that's going on I'm just
trying to talk about it you know just
spouting whatever comes to my mind I
actually do enjoy this should always sit
in the garden looking so tired I have a
stopped her from yeah I'm beginning to
think that this is gonna be a much
longer game than I thought so I might
have to break this up into parts or I
might just do a preview for you guys I
still though even though even though
we've been setting this up I still don't
see quite the purpose of it you know I
was hoping that there would be some
motivation that would be clear from the
get-go father didn't let me see her
final stages mmm my schoolwork was too
important and because of that I never
got to say goodbye
oh yeah that's a shame she was gone
and this this this games taking some sad
turns I'm beginning to think that this
guy is kinda somewhat crazy you know
successful psychopath hello
oh that's normal everything's nice a
fact please no no no no no no no no no
no no no that was a lot more nose than
was written to saying oh whoa hey what's
going on here what's all this said this
doesn't look like my bachelor pad
uh-huh yeah should the need arise for
what to store your bodies cuz you're a
psychopathic murderer I'm beginning to
think that is the truth okay what am I
looking for here what am I looking for
here hello hello
anything on the windows their heads in
these boxes out here we go uh-huh yeah
okay
okay this guy's normal I like this did I
put the knives away hey my pills pills
here okay I'll just climb right up on
this nice TVs and an ultra-wide
huh yeah is anyone seen American Psycho
or American Psycho pet or whatever the
movie is called one with Christian Bale
oh this looks like a really nice
mausoleum haha it's not exactly the game
I was expecting I was free v his
expectations yes is you were never good
enough where are you yes I was I was
good enough no you never good enough yes
Charlotte father okay yeah but I mean
actually it's in I'm uh it's actually
relief to get a game like this in the
indie development community because most
of the indie games that I play not that
they're bad but they're mostly just the
same kind of thing go find X number of Y
items you know run away from X thing
until you get to Y destination you know
those sort of things so it's nice to
take a more story driven narrative and I
do appreciate the attempt to get hmm
Christ why are you gonna dig up his body
what are you gonna do you are crazy yeah
I do appreciate the UM the attempt to
put a narrative into on these indie
games he was buried amongst the other
forgettable masses he wants to be with
okay yeah that's um that's good this is
normal behavior normal behavior for a
rich CEO of his own company bla bla bla
bla bla good for you men
you've reached new levels of psycho I'm
happy for you oh yeah you're doing good
buddy
you see human fix snaked antenna
she was an angel among savages
okay so Oh was that it
okay I thought it was something to do
them I must be trying to pursue my
father's grave and the voice acting is
not bad I mean it was not it's obviously
not a professional actor so yeah but
he's trying he's good trying to convey
emotion in his dialogue and that's
important okay so if father wasn't near
mothers his father in that big building
over there I'm just guessing
uh-huh yeah
alone to be the crazy person that you
really wanted to be good good great
congratulations
uh-huh for short as I appeared I
suddenly felt scared mm-hmm after all
this time it's been learning the ways of
a business tycoon son I didn't know what
to do yeah I just
yep I'm guessing you inherited your
father's company and that's a lot of
roses
apparently roses are bad for this guy
damn roses everywhere um maybe I don't
know who things have changed
this must have been some some day at
work if it triggered a episode like this
good god man you need to pull it
together he did yes
not good hungry well can you see it now
is this what you wanted father nice
nicely done
huzzah hello are you ordered oh boy what
what is it that you've done that he
would appreciate who nice pill stack I
feel like I wonder if your spy knows you
come to sending pseudo-scientific
bastard yeah bastard when did you turn
British bastard you but there's nothing
wrong with me I'm just exacting oh boy
here we go here's the kill room
this is American Psycho what's in here I
wonder I by the blood stain oh ah what
the hell
oh oh oh boy yeah duh how's it an
exploration into the mind of a
psychopath
huh I mean it was I expected it to be
longer I thought they were setting up
something different than that but
apparently the the experience they
wanted was purely story-driven and
that's okay I mean it was actually it
was actually pretty good I mean it's a
it's a refreshing take to have
just-just-just just a story push a game
forward and I mean a lot of games don't
focus around the story more and it may
seem slow like slow pacing and all that
but that's that's what you need to do to
set up the story effectively we're what
we were doing there if we were exploring
this guy's mind and how he thinks this
that was his everyday life his everyday
life was an exploration into insanity so
that was actually really good III did
thoroughly enjoy that and I wish a lot
more any games would tried to do that
because it wasn't exactly a complicated
game there was simple scripting there
was no animation that was necessary it
was all just static environments though
textures were a little bland I mean
there were just flat walls I mean they
could have gotten a little more depth
but that would have taken a lot more
work into and I'm obviously not a critic
or anything I'm just saying what could
have done to improve it and I would have
liked like more a more clear objective
of what I'm chasing like if there was
some element in there that showed from
the beginning that something wasn't
right
like everything seemed normal up until
the hospital moment if there was
something that was just a little bit of
a trigger that was different like
something that I needed a chaser or some
object or some or other but anyway it
was really good I really enjoyed it I
hope you all enjoyed it too it was just
released recently so give it a try
link is in the description below so
thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye higher
higher
ah little bit too low I can get this I'm
gonna spend the next 30 minutes right
here just trying to get it it'll hold 30
minutes later another hour later